in parts of southern europe like here in
spain forest fires are nothing new but
could conditions experienced in the
south soon be the norm elsewhere here in
britain the government's been holding
emergency meetings and for the first
time a red warning has been issued for
the heat rather than floods or winds
people are being warned there's a 50
chance of temperatures reaching 40
celsius more than one degree above the
all-time record
a studies found heat waves across europe
have increased three to four times
faster than in the rest of the northern
mid-latitudes including north america
and much of that is driven by changes to
atmospheric circulation known as the jet
stream whether or not that's directly
due to human activity scientists say our
continued use of fossil fuels means
we're already seeing what was previously
predicted for 2050. we're still
increasing greenhouse gases in the
atmosphere which means global
temperatures are increasing and this
means that this is probably something
that will be a relatively cool heat wave
in three decades to come so one thing
might also be to change that
conversation that actually
it's not
it's a question about life and death and
not just for the global south but also
for
citizens in the uk and despite news
reports concentrating on scenes like
this uk health authorities are warning
the heat can be deadly even for healthy
people
climate change has been driving extreme
temperatures for decades and the heat's
killing more and more people here in
england in the summer of 2020 more than
two and a half thousand excess deaths
were attributed to heat waves and
they've only become more intense and
more frequent since then the british red
cross predicts that the annual heat
waves death toll could have tripled by
the middle of this century
in much of europe the increase in heat
waves poses urgent questions about how
society adapts from education to working
patterns to transport and housing some
believe it's high time we faced up to a
hotter future nadine barbara al jazeera
london